dum-dum-dum dum-dum-dum dum-dum-dum
dum-dum-dum
superlame okay so uh
oh shit price you make it clear that
this is actually the second time we're
doing this here we are again you can
tell we were in second isn't there oh we
actually we shot with the set and
everything was looking great we have
these great angles and everything but
our mics sounded like yeah there's some
audio technical difficulties so if our
voices are raw for one thing that's cuz
this is the second time we're doing this
so uh and usually reanimated in that
first yeah so so usually we just go back
at whatever one just shoot the next day
but everyone is like the Man of Steel
don't go I'm into steel so it's we got
just give it to you man so um yeah so uh
I am General Zod and I am Jimmy Olsen
strangely not appearing in this movie I
think you were the bald guy I was
hitting on Wesley was it supposed to be
Jimmy that's creepy I don't know that I
said they didn't use me as armed so but
regardless this is sibling rivalry
Patrick Harris was not in this
i father believed if the world found out
who I really was they'd reject me
what do you think Superman begins oh I'm
sorry Man of Steel is the retelling all
of the most famous superheroes of all
time Superman and much like in the
Superman story a lot of is very much the
same Superman is an alien from another
planet and he is the last of his kind he
sent to earth to live among the humans
is raised as human but of course he's
not human being here gives him
unbelievable powers he can shoot lasers
from his eyes he has unbelievable
strength and of course he can fly but
bad news comes in the form of General
Zod who informs him that he is not alone
and that actually he has an army of
Kryptonians who are looking to kick his
ass and take over earth for their own
evil diabolical needs Man of Steel seems
to very much like to talk about the idea
of Superman but not Superman himself
watching this movie seems more like a
thesis about a film that you're never
allowed to see the dialog is constant
speech after speech after speech about
what it means to be Superman but there's
a big difference between speeches and
dialogue because of this the actors in
this movie who have all given a good
performance at least one point in their
career are bland and forgettable but you
can't blame them for that the script
gives them nothing to work with
just speech after speech after speech
but Superman doesn't even listen to half
of the speeches being made as it seems
he sure makes up his own rules he spends
less time trying to actually look after
the people of Metropolis and instead
destroy Metropolis for cool action
scenes the action scenes are cool and
the camera isn't shaking so much that
you can see them for a character who's
supposed to represent the heart of the
American superhero I was really shocked
at how incredibly heartless this was
there was no personality to these
characters they were all so bland and
forgettable when they are usually so
distinct and memorable if you want a
version of the Superman story that has
much more heart and much more character
and much more thought I would say go to
the original Richard Donner version or
if you want to go for a reboot that's
much more effective I would say go to
the Saturday morning cartoon done by the
same people who did Batman the Animated
Series in that hour and a half pilot
they got more thought and more heart in
it than anything in this film and if an
hour and a half Saturday morning cartoon
with the limitation
of an hour-and-a-half morning cartoon
can get closer to the heart of what
Superman is than a three hour movie that
had almost no limitation on its budget I
think the problem is that the filmmakers
in this movie had to go watch more
Saturday morning cartoons
Rob uh needs more otisburg
there's a distinct lack of otisburg
in this movie that that's what was
obviously missing idols this could have
pulled it all together well come over
stir Luthor you got everything is bad we
had a bet going into this who is going
to be the most bland actor I had gone
with Russell Crowe
I actually pressure on him yes I could I
went with Russell Crowe fresh off of
Lima zurab but you can't beat the
blandness of the cost guys what was
Kevin Costner and I I was just like when
it was all said and done I cough it up
yeah yeah it's there was no contest
Russell Crowe as bland as he was was
still not as bad as Kevin Kahn do so
thank you so much that that being said
both Amy Adams and Michael Shannon were
even blander and Kevin Costner and
Russell Crowe so I consider it a draw
okay okay I'll give you that I'll give
you that
um and that was a refreshing surprise
thank you movie because I would not have
guessed I'd always surprise you that was
the only surprise in this movie I would
not have guessed that Michael Shannon
and Amy Adams would have been the most
boring performance in the smell I'm
gonna say this first cuz this has been
uh yeah on the go they're gonna be rant
I am going on a rant because this has
been bothering I've seen every Nolan
fanboy come out of the woodwork and go
on and on where if you criticize this
movie all of a sudden that's you don't
get it you're just an evil critic you
snooty bastards in your ivory towers
when now a good movie this is the
people's movie if ivory towers yeah I
was like where's my I didn't know bad
yeah and it's just like critics just
don't understand they've always hated
Nolan I love this when is Christopher
Nolan become an underdog Christopher
Nolan is a director who has made how
many projects
now eight nine ten ten movies in a row
that have been universally loved by
critics the lowest-scoring one I think
I'm Ron tomatoes is 76% maybe I think
the prestige maybe Louis he is a media
and critical darling every critic out
there loves this guy but now listen
because they want a criticized Man of
Steel you people just hate nolan the
critics hate Nolan I'm like everybody
loves
every critic whelps Christopher Nolan's
obviously you figured that out and saw
the fight there only by critics who
didn't like the Dark Knight so he said
okay I have to tell the story over and
over and over even if it's a story that
has nothing to do with the Dark Knight
Missy and this is a problem so going in
this now I'm gonna say in the comments
section if you try to give me the you're
just a critic you don't get it oh well
you just don't like Crispin Olin I will
defend Dark Knight to my dying day as a
great movie so when I say I don't like
Man of Steel don't bother coming back
with that BS excuse just don't even
bother where's the microphone man it's a
problem yeah John give me that cuz I
like Christopher Nolan I like a lot of
what he did in the Batman trilogy so
don't
that being said then this sock yeah okay
this is a pretty bad movie
well I loved what you were going into uh
what Chris or no I might as well talk
about cuz you've gone to such great
detail and I tend to agree I think since
Dark Knight Rises he's tried to recreate
the Batman Begins and Dark Knight feel
just constantly in places where it's not
needed and what fascinated me is that I
like Christopher Nolan and Zack Snyder
and what I like about them is that they
constantly come at ideas and stories
from different angles and different
ideas you think in there so you think of
300 they're true to their vision in this
film there is no vision it's like
whatever Snyder was is gone and whatever
pure vision Nolan had it's this weird
mix it's like Snyder's been nullified
nullify his Nolan defied Nolan fied so
all of the things that made 300 Watchmen
at least very entertaining to watch the
the bright
colors um you know the action that that
sort of vision that Schneider has love
it or hate it completely gone in this
movie to a shaky cam yeah tripods invest
jag-offs seriously I get if you want to
make it realistic by putting some shaky
cam not easy to make when it's shaking
that word I'd in mind that I'm like okay
you're trying to get a more realistic
feel Abrams will sometimes do the same
thing there was a scene in the intro of
this film where Zod walks in and he's
talking to some ridiculously costumed
senators from Krypton and this this old
ladies sitting there just like this and
I swear to god she's just because of the
cameras and I'm like these two are
talking why are you shaking the camera
this makes no sense and the entire movie
is shot this wait some of that I thought
Leamas Rob may have set the standard for
obnoxious cinematographer Hunger Games
the out more Hunger Games like both of
those have really obnoxious
cinematography this blows those two out
of the water I will give this movie
credit it added one new element that I
thought was pretty good and that was the
concept that his superpowers have messed
him up because he has x-ray vision
there's a good idea
there's a brilliant scene with his
mother who's the only useful woman in
this film and she does one thing and
it's this one scene otherwise women have
just been written out of this movie now
can loud that the Earth's at check was
cool okay here's a chick is cool but
there's nothing I mean there's nothing
there ROI goal is to kick Superman's ass
I mean let me ask you this and this is
another problem you know apart from the
mother who says listen to my voice focus
on me you know and you'll be able to get
through this we'll work through your
powers and the way they're driving you
nuts because it's basically make
Superman kind of schizophrenic because
he's seeing hearing all of these things
with his powers brilliant scene
absolutely bring the only new thing
added to this you know mythos that I
really like apart from that what does
Louis do what do you need Louis for oh I
I agree honestly I don't think it's
universe I think it's terrific Eric yeah
you could have written her out of this
movie and you would have lost not a
thing in fact that the barians will show
you character at the variants she shows
up on an airplane as a part of a secret
mission and push a button
yeah to push a button then it could have
told anybody how to do that and she
couldn't even do that right but Batman
Begins did that this movie did not and
this I think is the one the major
slip-ups when Batman Begins starts he
has flashbacks to his childhood but the
flashbacks are told in order you see him
discover the cape you see him interact
with the pair's you see the parents die
and then you cut back to the present day
that's what you do
this as soon as he lands on the planet
he's a fisherman then he's 12 years old
then he's a teenager he's a child again
but something like Batman Begins pulls
it off because it told the flash bags in
order so you see the progression you see
the character grow this is so out of
order you can never connect with this
count and the way it's edited together
it's there's this this trick which is
slow moment
flash bang with these little tease
action seeds or some time that's trying
to develop character oh boy tornado
explosion oh and it's always like this
little moment that just lasts all of 10
seconds and then what do we get after
that I won't be again I'm sad and here's
the thing I think a lot of people
overlook is when you look at the Richard
Donner fella a lot of people like to say
all that that film is corny it's a corny
boy and it is but I think people mistake
that corny you know and upbeat and
colorful uh is not does not carry weight
and is not heavy and is not dramatic if
you watch that film if you watch pretty
much the exact same amount of time that
they have to get Superman all Krypton to
the planet the father play by Brando has
to say goodbye to his son has to say
that the planets going to explore has to
say that he's going to not tell anybody
but still allow this to happen he has to
make the sacrifice you feel so much for
them
everything is there that needs to be
there for the drama of Superman and it
is so well done and it is cornea is
upbeat but that does not mean it has to
be super dark in order to get drama
drama kiss anywhere it is not seven tons
the original Donner Superman was a film
that had adult themes but was aimed at
the entire family in most respects this
film is aimed at 14 year olds mmm it's
an amazing Islamic ground yeah it's
literally aimed at the transformer crowd
and you know I mean the thing is the
only response I'm seeing from people is
well I
debt like okay I I like david lynch's
dune I like Batman Returns I'm not
defending them as great movies it's just
not going to happen you know we all have
our guilty pleasures and if you like it
you like it that's fine but it's the way
the the Nolan fanboys have come out of
the woodwork to say that you know this
is one of the greats I mean I'm just
going to ask you straight up this this
movie is the one you're going to rally
around you know we a dark now 80 you
know we've we've gone to the adventures
we have this is the one that you feel
the need to go how dare you not like Man
of Steel this is fucking Superman no
really when it comes down to it America
has to mythology's too cuz Batman's not
a mythology he's pretty human to
mythology Superman in Star Wars this is
the closest thing to an American
mythology we have if there is one thing
that incredible kazoo from Flintstones
come on I mean if there is one thing on
the planet that if you're given 225 250
million dollars the guy who gave you the
Dark Knight you know the same
screenwriters you know but all of this
pedigree that you cannot mess up that
you do not want to settle for sloppy
seconds for it is Superman and when it's
all said and done it's just another
superhero movie red letter media they
talked about why the prequels the Star
Wars did not work and how you could
analyze you could say in just a few
words what the characters in the
original Star Wars films were like and
you can't do that with the prequels I
will say that here just because they are
they're identifiable names from
characters you do remember none of those
characteristics carry over here if I was
to see this knowing nothing about these
categories I mean yes I would know
nothing about laws I would know nothing
about Superman would know nothing about
I don't know just as much sod that he
says yeah or as odd or the fire or any
of these people there are no
characteristics of these people Superman
is a symbol so let's try as hard as we
can to tell the story of a symbol and
not the story of a character we are
looking at speeches about characters not
characters themselves yeah and you just
cannot replace the two that there it is
man I hope we successful
we pissed most of you off and if you
wanna hear is going to even more detail
fidgeting I love the dark night I loved
Nolan I liked Snyder's films I did not
like this movie and if you want yours go
into even more detail even though this
is probably more the you deep if you
want this talk about the spoilers in the
film just go below to spoiler corner and
we will talk more about that until then
REM General Zod I'm tired